dans l'actualité de ce jour vous en
parlais tout à l'heure cette réunion de
la commission européenne à strasbourg
exceptionnellement avec un enjeu comment
diversifier les sources d'énergie pour
être moins dépendant de moscou sur la
seule année 2000 21 pour vous donner un
ordre d'idée l'union européenne importer
environ 45% de gaz depuis elle a réussi
bonjour à vous pierre bénazet vous êtes
notre correspondant à bruxelles piermont
on apprend d'ailleurs à l'instant que
les états unis vont interdire
l'importation pétrole russe à un embargo
avait été établi dès les premiers jours
de ce conflit où est-ce qu'on en est
alors en réalité pour les européens
c'est un véritable casse tête il ya
cette décision américaine les états unis
avaient tenté un petit peu en quelque
sorte de tordre le bras aux européens
avec cette annonce publique qui avait
été faite dimanche par anthony blinken
le ministre américain des affaires
étrangères pour suivre cet exemple qui
avait été mis par le canada qui avait
décidé lui-même d'interdire
l'importation de pétrole brut en
provenance de russie vous lisiez les
importations sont à un très haut niveau
dans l'union européenne les importations
russes que ce soit d'ailleurs pour le
pétrole brut mais aussi pour le gaz et
pour le charbon on est quasiment à 46%
de dépendance des importations russes
pour le charbon donc il n'y a pas que
les hydrocarbures ce sont des
dépendances qui concerne à la fois des
pays d'europe centrale et orientale
comme par exemple la finlande la
république tchèque la slovaquie la
hongrie mais aussi l'allemagne dans une
très large mesure et puis par exemple
l'italie on sent donc que les européens
sont extrêmement tiraillés par leur
volonté politique d'émettre un signal
fort sur les hydrocarbures russes mais
leur dépendance dont on parlait à
l'instant cette dépendance il va se
traduire par une volonté de la
commission européenne de proposer une
extension de la boîte à outils en
quelque sorte diversifier les
approvisionnements que ça soit par
l'amélioration de l'interconnexion des
réseaux des méthaniers passé au biogaz
passer au gaz naturel liquéfié passé à
l'hydrogène enfin beaucoup d'outils que
la commission européenne va mettre sur
la table on y réfléchit actuellement
on devrait s'engager au mieux ça peut
être lors du sommet européen de
versailles léon les 12 11 et le 12 les
dix séances parlons à un plafond maximal
d' importations d'hydrocarbures de la
russie c'est en tout cas une des pistes
qui sont évoqués pour l'instant et puis
d'autres pistes sont à l'étude pierre
les européens réfléchissent à à d'autres
sanctions pour maintenir une sorte de
pression constante sur moscou est ce
qu'on sait ce qui est déjà envisagée et
bien c'est ça la pression constante
c'est exactement ce que vous dites on
essaye tous les jours en quelque sorte
enfin en tout cas régulièrement de
rajouter une nouvelle couche à ces
sanctions pour toucher la russie le plus
possible il y a eu par exemple
politiquement ce signal envoyé hier par
la commission par les ambassadeurs
représentants permanents des 27 à
bruxelles qui demandent à la commission
d'évaluer les candidatures européennes
de l'ukraine de la moldavie et de la
géorgie aujourd'hui on pense à étendre
les sanctions à de nouveaux oligarques
russes on envisage aussi de priver
l'accès à au réseau inter-bancaire swift
pour trois nouvelles banques russes à
s'attaquer aux cryptes monnaie russe et
puis afin d'empêcher le système
financier russe de contourner les
sanctions européennes de couper aussi
l'accès des banques biélorusse au réseau
inter-bancaire swift de manière à avoir
une étanchéité des systèmes financiers
pour que la russie ne puisse plus
approvisionné en capitaux sur les places
financières mondiales merci beaucoup
pierre fier